the nfc west now has a great collection
of quarterbacks when you consider
assuming the stafford deal becomes
official on march 17
kyler murray russell wilson the guy that
stands out right now chris
is jimmy garoppolo because we don't know
that he's going to be there
and when you see that the 49ers got
involved in the matthew stafford
sweepstakes it makes you wonder are they
going to try to get desean watson
there was a lot of buzz yesterday about
the obvious possibility that they would
try to trade for kirk cousins
um where do you think this is going to
go
well i i just i feel like you know
reading the tea leaves and everything
just the
paying attention to the 49ers football
team all year
like we do talking about it everything
like that
i mean it seems like they're looking to
try to move on from jimmy garoppolo or
see if they can get
some sort of upgrade at the quarterback
position and i understand it
you know i mean two things like we
talked about jimmy garoppolo can't stay
healthy
they have a really good team it's a
super bowl type of team
and you know if if they so they either
got to get a quarterback who can play
and be out there consistently
or get a top-tier backup type
quarterback
but i think the other thing like to your
point mike and like what you're talking
about
you know the 49ers shanahan he's in the
nfc west like you're talking about he's
seeing russell wilson and kyler murray
and he got to see a few other
quarterbacks and mahomes in the super
bowl last year
you know he's got to look at it and go
wait uh
one of these guys who can make plays it
doesn't always have to be on me and the
offense delivering
all the time and that's where i got to
think they're looking for that upgrade
but the injury thing has got to be a
real concern for that organization
23 games missed by jimmy garoppolo in
the past
three seasons now 2019 he didn't miss a
game
but they went into that bob greasy mode
with him in the postseason when kyle
shanahan got freaked out by some balls
that
garoppolo threw against the vikings that
could have been picked off one was
two weren't all three were in the
direction of eric kendricks
and then you've got uh this year
missing the the ten games with the ankle
injury
at some point you've just got to
consider your options 2.8 million
dollars is the cap charge that would
attach
to trading or or cutting jimmy garoppolo
there's some thought that maybe they
could trade him right back to the
patriots
but then who do the 49ers end up with
and chris we have a question
from jbo 799 2900 got to get the numbers
right
please tell me if cousins to the niners
smoke has
fire when would this need to go down
the hashtag skull at the very end you
don't see that on the screen but the
hashtag skull at the end is a giveaway
because
there are plenty of vikings fans that
would love
to see the vikings offload kirk cousins
we'll talk about that angle in a minute
for now though
cousins to the 49ers and some 49ers fans
is like what's the difference between
him and garoppolo well one difference is
cousins doesn't get injured and the
other difference is he's known that
offense since 2012.
now he's he's learned others since then
but he could go back to
that mode that he was in when he was
with kyle shanahan relearn the offense
and run the offense the way he did in
washington
definitely run it like he did in
washington do all the things jimmy
garoppolo does
and then some kirk cousins is better
than jimmy garoppolo as a quarterback
and my assessment
i i think there's a clear advantage to
cousins
you say what you want about kirk cousins
it's not special
like you've always talked about he's not
going to make backyard
you know scramble type plays and do that
but we know jimmy garoppolo is not that
guy either
so shanahan's comfortable with that type
of player but the one difference to me
between cousins and garoppolo
is just the pure throwing aspect cousins
is a pure thrower
he is gifted that way it might not be
the strongest arm you've ever seen
but it's punny strong and the way they
uncork the ball
down the field hey they had one of the
more aggressive
deep passing passing games in all of
football this year
i mean it wasn't dink and dunk it was
justin jefferson 40 yards down the field
adam thielen 30 yards over here
hey back to justin jefferson 20 yards
over the middle
they look for big throws in the pass
game and that to me
is where would be a huge upgrade because
you know you mentioned it
the struggles in the playoffs last year
a very
average super bowl performance by jimmy
garoppolo
to cap that off and then not bringing
anything physically elite or special to
the field as a quarterback
and then you're injured a lot i i don't
know how you could think that you would
just get the red carpet rolled out for
you and definitely get to come back and
be the starting quarterback
amazing to think that the quarterback of
the super bowl representative for 2018
and 2019 both gone out of the nfc
west in the same cycle jared goff
dumped and now jimmy garoppolo
potentially dumped
think about kirk cousins and i'm ready
to give him some praise this is
he loves him face i love him
kirk cousins knows how to stay within
his abilities he knows the limits he's
very self-aware
of his abilities on the football field
and that's one of the ways you get
injured chris
when you start trying to do things that
you're not built to do
that's when you set yourself up to get
hit in an awkward way
you're you're straining too hard you're
trying too hard to trying to will your
body to do something it's just not wired
to do
when kirk cousins knows the play's over
the play's over
you're never going to see kirk cousins
drop a shoulder at the sideline and tear
his acl like jimmy garoppolo did
you're never going to see kirk cousins
get caught in this massive bodies and
sprain his ankle
when it's going down he's down it's done
that's it
and that's one of the reasons why he's
able to suit up and play every week and
that's one of the key components
of being a franchise quarterback if if
we
if we broaden the definition because i
don't know how many there are
but you got to be available to play to
be in the conversation and
kirk cousins always is now the other
side of it
i wrote about this last night because
because i you know
look we we've known that kyle shanahan's
been interested in a kirk cousins
reunion that was three years ago but
maybe it could happen now what was pre
garoppolo maybe it could happen now i
don't think the vikings are going to
want to let him go
because if the vikings let him go what
are they going to do
it's not like there's some guy out there
that's going to be dramatically better
than kirk cousins and if you move on
from cousins
that's how you move a step closer toward
getting everybody fired you keep
cousins you may be good enough to keep
everyone around for another year
you get rid of cousins what are you
gonna do mitchell trubisky no disrespect
i'm
throwing out names like it's not like
there's a ton of names out there where
you look at it and say well that guy's
better than kirk cousins
and you put him into a new team a new
offense a new everything
he's not going to be as good as kirk
cousins cousins isn't going to take you
to the super bowl
but he's not going to get everybody
fired either and i think that's going to
be a factor for the vikings and
they're not going to want to give them
away i i don't know what the vikings
would do at quarterback
without cousins for 2021 i agree that's
where i think that
i don't know if i can get be you know
behind it i don't know if it makes sense
for the minnesota vikings
unless they're totally going okay fine
we're gonna trade them you know get some
pics and and really try to
semi rebuild here on the run again but
you're right that doesn't
doesn't seem that's the way that's not
gonna be right for mike zimmer at this
point of his career
so i have a hard time thinking that and
i don't think they're just going to be
like
hey you know you give us jimmy garoppolo
we'll give you kirk cousins and a few
picks i don't know if they're going to
be happy about that either
because again yeah they might like jimmy
garoppolo but
he's not healthy ever so that's going to
hurt his trade value or
a team just saying yeah we want him we
want the guy who plays
60 of the time that's a tough one i
think this whole 49ers quarterback
situation
very fascinating i really do um i have
zero inside knowledge of the situation
just to be clear on that
this is a team i don't i do this is
where
i i don't hear from kyle shanahan at all
he doesn't want to tell me anything what
so my big mouth can go on here and
and introduce it to the whole world he
wants nothing to do with me right now
so it's been a little while since we
talked um
but i'm smart enough and i follow his
team
to to know that that's got to be an
issue we see that they were in the trade
market for a matthew stafford we've
heard the mum
you know the murmurs and mumbles out
there that are
you know surrounding their quarterback
situation
and they're a super bowl team and
they're not sure about their quarterback
and uh that's going to be something to
watch here you know for the next few
weeks
and a point you made yesterday the teams
that were at the table for matthew
stafford are the first ones we need to
look at to be at the table for deshawn
watson but
the price is a lot higher so whereas a
team like the 49ers may have been
willing to put together a package for
matthew stafford are they
really going to break the bank from a
draft pick standpoint
for the guy they could have had in 2017
psychologically that's got to be tough
for the 49ers to do
give up three first-round picks for the
guy that we could have had
and we didn't take him tough tough tough
one to justify so i don't know what the
49ers are going to do
but it sure feels like they're looking
for alternatives to
jimmy garoppolo hi i'm mike tarico and
thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports